here are this week's top movies hey babe  lined woman recovers her site only to  realize that her marriage is in danger  and all I see is you I could ask you the  same thing the truth will set you free  in jigsaw a notorious serial killer long  thought dead becomes the primary suspect  in a series of gruesome deaths mom a  home invasion reveals an unlikely  suspect of a criminal conspiracy in  suburbicon nothing like this ever  happens here this is a safe place it why  see what's hot in theaters with this  week's fantasy pation so what's your  weekend ticket going to be let us know  by commenting see you next time on  weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]